from our good friends over at clown
world did we talk about this one yet guy
with mask got mad because some guy walks
too close to him without wearing a mask
yes this is uh This Is Where We Are
turn the volume down
[Music]
you're gonna go to jail look at these
people with the masks on right
so so hold on just like consider this
this guy is mad that some guy was close
and without a mask on so he wants to get
closer to him yeah it's always the
tightest mask too with these people and
they get so mad maybe it's the pressure
you know the pressure and it's causing
their head to yeah serious question
though with stuff like this
what happened to people's brains now
hold on did they never have one or did
something break it they were easily they
were fragile to begin with
I think a lot of these people I think
hope it broke people's brains bro what
do you think will happen if you have
people stuck inside of houses for two
years straight and having a fear you
know what I'm saying like like what you
know something's on something has to
mentally happen there because I'm in a
disco with a lot of people including
liberals and Liberals are really crazy
this dude said he literally the furthest
he went out of his house was his
backyard for two years straight and I
said
Howard Stern said he didn't leave his
house for almost like two years what
because he was afraid to do so yeah and
just a couple weeks ago he did to have
dinner with some friends that's right
and other otherwise he was too scared to
go outside that's not even good for your
immune system it's horrible for it yeah
there's people talking about superflues
and and super bacterial infections
because people's immune system is isn't
up to shape like it like it should have
been with normal human conflict what
happened to these people no no for real
cause like Howard Stern was a crazy guy
back in the day now he's hiding in his
basement for two years yeah did
something happen to their brains I think
if they know what well you fear they can
control you and these people bought into
the fear of kovid my theory is that a
lot of smart people understand that the
gut and brain are related so they first
launched a bigger attack when it came to
destroying our food which destroyed our
gut with our gut being destroyed
therefore people's brains are destroyed
and uh I think people take advantage of
that situation I think it was a
deliberate move I think it was a
conspiracy that was orchestrated by some
very powerful individuals that pulled
off the larger uh destruction of
people's mental health and what better
way to of course control someone than to
of course destroy their cognitive
ability to think for themselves to think
strongly to be independent than to of
course be emotionally weak and uh easily
controlled half fructose corn syrup all
the soil seed oils seed oil the food
pyramid all the chemicals that they put
in there uh chemicals that they keep
changing the name of so people don't
find it uh so I think I think you know a
lot of this was orchestrated top down I
don't think it's an accident I don't
think it was incentivized because of
profit there are some layers to it where
some people are incentivized by by uh by
the money especially when it comes to
using corn and soy which is subsidized
by the government but I think the bigger
reason why it's subsidized is because of
these larger control efforts which by in
part come along with the larger distrib
attribution of it I agree they how many
simulations did they run of this type of
thing before we got what we got but
that's obviously like I think a top-down
thing but then when you think of these
people I had so many friends who I
thought who grew up we were punk rock
anti-establishment and they just bought
into the establishment yeah so hard I
was I was dizzy at first I thought I was
crazy because I was surrounded by so
many people who really bought it people
literally are starting to have panic
attacks out of nowhere they're driving
their car and they start freaking out
now if you have someone who's not in
control of their nervous system or their
immune system if you have someone
already on the verge of freaking out you
just add a couple ingredients to that
you add the fear monitoring you add the
videos from China of people just falling
down and collapsing you add politicians
telling you to go to Chinatown you're
creating a recipe for disaster and and I
think you know a lot of this is more
planned than we we even give it credit
to because if you look at every step of
the way it's almost as if everything was
engineered from the very start to get us
in into this mess I was at Blaze Studios
a couple years back and uh Glenn back
the studio they got these old newspapers
on the walls
and as I'm waiting I'm reading one of
them and it was a story from like 1800s
where some dude walked out of a bar and
he's like chilling and then some other
guy walks out and just puts a gun to his
chest and shoots him
and it was like a crazy story and I'm
like man was that what it was like back
then just like you're hanging out at a
bar and then someone randomly shoots you
and then I paused and thought for a
second and I was like that's literally
what it was like growing up in Chicago
so maybe maybe maybe actually wasn't
that crazy back then and people actually
just do crazy stuff but then I started
thinking about how a lot of these people
like Howard Stern are terrified of death
and I was thinking about how back then a
lot of people weren't maybe I don't know
we're so comfortable we're so gluttonous
we're so safe that we just are genuinely
terrified of injury or death whereas
back in the day people were like you
might die well people also don't have
God and they don't have a bigger
connection
that's the spirit and the soul but and
and I think you know a Godless Society
is also leading to individuals not
having a better understanding of of our
existence and this is for leaving that
that emptiness is being filled with
corporations so let me ask you Bryson
and maybe maybe what's happening the
reason these people are so terrified of
covid is because their view is this is
all I am and all I ever will be and more
spiritual more philosophical and more
religious people are kind of like I'm
not super worried about it like you know
the world is the way it is and there's
something waiting for me afterwards so
when you have God you have to think
about it life is bigger than you so your
your self is not the main thing in in
Western societies mainly the me me me me
me culture is why everything is becoming
more Galaxy everybody is solely caring
about themselves so of course you're
going to fear death if you think this is
the end-all be y'all and you you don't
have God there's nothing bigger than you
to think about so you are your God at
that point everybody's gonna have a God
whether you like it or not and a lot of
people God is them is themselves so I
think that's the issue in uh in our
society and I think it's plaguing
Western societies period I think it's a
materialism problem yep right if you
don't have God you start to worship the
things you have to yeah we meet it we
humans we need something like that to be
in front of us we need we we sort of are
hardwired to have some type of Idols
that's why everybody had leaders every
tribe has a leader you can go find a
random tribe in in the jungle right now
I bet you it's going to be a leader you
know what I'm saying she is but if
you're in charge right and you have a
lot of power what better way than to
kind of bamboozle everyone from
worshiping something spiritual something
deeper being there from their family
members what better way than to convince
them to worship their Disney stars or
their celebrities or they're politicians
that are literally created in in in in
these effigies in these candles in these
in these dolls where right now we have
fouchy candles we have Andrew Como
candles they have replaced normal
religion with the religion of the state
the religion of of the cult which is
essentially a corporatist banking agenda
that is destroying people of any kind of
spiritual deeper existence and uh pretty
much uh exchanging it with obedience to
the state we need Jesus everybody needs
Jesus the state should discuss everybody
and this is one of the things I pressed
with yay because he was like he's
looking for advice everywhere even like
with you in here like he's asking people
questions and I'm like all right one
thing I've heard you do is like
sometimes you just say the word Tuskegee
and we don't talk about it but like if
you actually expand on that to a large
audience you will start to show people
why they should fear this government
because they will do terrible things to
you always and forever and because we
just like keep a blind eye to it I'm
like and that's just one example of of
many things that this government has
done to his own people and we don't even
know the worst of it right yeah imagine
how bad it gets about the stuff we still
don't even know about I mean we found
out about about the island and and the
children that were sent there for
politicians to do whatever they wanted
to do with lots of them also missing
that's that's what we know that that's
only one percent of what we know yeah
like go go look up after the show
everybody what what America did for and
the Steve Unit 731 in Japan oh yeah yeah
if you want to feel disgusting unit unit
uh was it seven seven three one yeah
they would take prisoners and then stick
their arms through a hole into Sub-Zero
temperatures to freeze while still
attaching their body right and then they
would pull it in and shatter the arm to
see what would happen correct wow yes
there was babies born in captivity and
they would do things to them they would
they would vivisec people and have them
eat their own organs we all been to CIA
still influences journalism you know
they said they they said they stopped it
though in court oh then it must be
they're very trustworthy you can always
trust those guys it's not like they ever
lied before I got one for you I got one
for you go back in time 20 years and go
to a CIA IA or FBI agent in telum 20
years from now
people in this country will have their
own shows that they start and launch to
the tune of millions of people watching
every night
and they will be able to expose
everything that is you're doing
would they believe you no they
controlled everything
but but I'll tell you this if you ever
do go back in time don't warn them
yeah we like this right
we want to be able to you know call them
out that's why I think it's like a
tremendous white pill you know the fact
that we get to make fun of these guys
who like he's wearing a mask and he's
freaking out and he's screaming at some
other guy the fact that they can be the
subject of ridicule it'll change things
the fact that the FBI isn't able to get
away with a lot of the stuff they're
doing it'll change things I mean the
changes are happening all around us
that's why the internet is so
bittersweet it's sweet because we we do
have access we have access to
information and we can you know Freedom
of Information that however much you
think that tell us and we can get on
here and expose people to everybody's
platforms but at the same time the
internet is so toxic too it's like a big
high school do you think the pros
outweigh the cons
no yeah I I don't know I go back and
forth because it's like it's all
connecting and like all the things we
got to share the disinformation the past
two years and you know what maybe yes
because if everything was still
controlled somebody as crazy as me would
not have like a Billboard Chart and song
like come on bro right here you get to
share music and all of our art and we
get to talk freely for the most part
even on sometimes but like I want to be
a t-shirt vendor exactly so true see
look at all the positivity we're
creating okay maybe even I will even
maybe even I'll go with that because
there are horrible things that it does
too there's another thing about it
people have to have access like let's
talk women for example they had to have
access to like magazines to understand
what the beauty standards were and I can
just go on Instagram and everybody's
trying to look like Whoever has 10
million followers you know everybody
want to be Kylie Jenner or Kim
Kardashian the same exact person yeah
almost identical yeah almost every last
one those are clones yeah clones fake
books for sure Botox
yeah fake lips looks like they got
punches in the mouth have you seen the
girls with the super long nails okay I'm
just going off yeah
now we're hitting the good issues yeah I
was talking about it earlier man there's
no purpose
people have no no goal they have no plan
they don't know what they're alive for
Washington Post put up this article
saying that like young people are
suffering from extreme levels of
depression like not seen before yeah
because they got nothing to live for
they're Wayward
look back in the day people had religion
Faith got right
today a lot of people still do but uh 20
30 years ago people had their Community
they had their classes they had their
state you know uh state championships or
whatever they'd go and they'd watch the
community and cheer them on there was
something they focused on there was
something they were working for today
they have nothing yeah so what do they
do they go on Instagram and they say
what will get me social satisfaction I
need more likes what gets me more likes
garbage yeah bazungus garbage generic
content booty shaking and then what
happens when you don't get the likes
anymore
like people's people's psyches are just
shattered think about this right you can
go to the poorest country in Africa take
your pick
and I bet you the United States of
America has a higher rate of depression
agreed yeah yeah I would also say
um you said people need Jesus yeah
that's one way to put it I would simply
put it this way people with Jesus are
doing better than people without facts
that this is not me making a religious
statement what I'm saying is the people
who have no faith and no plan have have
higher rates of mental illness have
higher rates of depression
and the people who have religion have
something anchoring them
it's bigger than us we don't when you
truly you know in the word of God are
usually trying to live a different
lifestyle uh I mean you don't really
have time to be depressed you know you
start changing your life for god like
people don't understand I have never
been depressed in my life and I've been
celibate 13 years almost because I'm
waiting for marriage you know what I'm
saying I don't get drunk I've never
tried any drug period I've never been on
pills or anything and I am like so happy
that's why people think people think
like right just don't care about
anything why who cares bro I just say
what I want and in my in my mind I have
the armor of God on and it's about God
so you know what they say misery loves
company right so when when uh the left
started mocking Ben Shapiro because he
was a virgin until he got married they
were like haha look at him look at he's
a virgin and he was like and then
they're like haha we're making fun of
you and he was like this is something I
wanted like what are you talking about
but they want to drag you into their
world where they have higher rates of
depression higher rates of architecture
drug addiction uh alcohol no families
yep thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time